let's talk about uh wikileaks all right
so um
are you're like a wikileaks confidant i
guess or like
how would you describe yourself in that
capacity this what we're talking about
trump mind you too this is we're
i'm tying it together um i don't know
i'm a friend of julian's i'm a
longtime supporter i've covered them
extensively i've written hundreds of
articles
about wikileaks um
yeah you you were saying before like if
it wasn't for the riots you wouldn't
have voted for trump because of what
happened to assange
yeah i mean if somebody is you know
going after your friend would you
well what what did trump do so
let me start real quick just for people
who might not be aware wikileaks is
essentially just a news publication
right they but they they
the the core of it is they take leaks
whistleblowers and they publish
all news outlets do this well not all
but most
but news outlets also will write like
you know it rained today and there's
like a cat in the tree
but they'll take leaks the new york
times writes about a bunch of different
things including leaks wikileaks like
focus on
they'll use software based on wikileaks
now to get an anonymous submission right
the dropbox
so julian assange has basically been
detained forcibly um under house arrest
sort of he was in the ecuadorian embassy
for a long time when they finally are
like dropping the charges
the u.s swoops in and arrests him and
now they're trying to extradite him
and uh i don't know how much i'm
supposed to say well they read your
testimony right yeah
it's online trump did it yeah trump is
the one who who ordered assange's arrest
i don't get it trump said he loved
wikileaks
and now all of a sudden he's putting
assange through all of this
well he i think trump surrounded himself
with a lot of very
very bad people i mean we had bolton
pompeo
um it was he hired a lot of bushies you
know it's not the same republican party
as the trump people and
those people certainly don't care about
a free press
um but yeah he
he ordered it and jennifer robinson
recently testified too that you know
there was a meeting
and they offered julian assange apart in
exchange for giving up his source
on the dc and email leaks right are the
the dnc yes or was it the dccc or it was
the dnc right the dnc leaks
so julian assange came to to possess
emails from the dnc and it was very very
bad for the democrats yes
and donald trump wants to know how he
got this well
i mean donald trump's whole present
predator
i can't talk his whole presidency has
been plagued by
russia russia russia everything's russia
you won because of russia
and so by by finding out wikileaks
source
because julian's repeatedly said it
wasn't a state actor and he's a very
honest man
um he would finally be able to put that
to bed it would clear trump
it would clear his name wouldn't this is
a really tough question
uh it's a really it's a really uh
difficult ethical conundrum
julian assange can't give up his sources
no it would discredit everything he's
ever done
it would destroy the organization and it
would put at risk
his sources yeah so i think a lot of
people
that there's the the conspiracy theory
of
who leaked to it uh who leaked the
information wikileaks
but assuming that this so i guess the
conspiracy theory is seth rich
they claim that seth rich did it but uh
the the media claims it was russia
i guess it was what intelligence
agencies claimed it was russia as well
right but assange said absolutely not
then who was that other guy who claimed
it was not russia because he received
the documents from
former ambassador craig murray craig
murray said that
so it's either uh it could
i mean at this point i have no idea who
who could have been maybe craig murray
assange
they're both lying maybe the theories
are wrong
or maybe there's someone we don't know
about and if assange gave him up
it would put this person's life in
jeopardy and assange won't give up that
information
right and it could be it could have been
multiple multiple people i mean
he's not going to tell anyone and he
shouldn't and he doesn't owe anybody
that um you know people want people are
like well he needs to do this because
her democracy is falling apart
and it's like he doesn't know you
anything he gave you the information
to make an informed decision about your
election and then
everybody forgot about him and left him
in an embassy for two more years to rob
while trump was president and could have
pardoned him why does he owe anybody
anything and so when he refused the deal
uh the you know wikileaks lawyers argued
that that's when
they decided to prosecute him because
now they're going to take him by force
and force them to give it up
right and that's that's a violation of
ethics
and you know it's it really is a
challenge because i i feel that that
part of me where it's like
if we can get confirmation that it
really wasn't russia
that would destroy like maybe not maybe
not completely because the establishment
lies all the time and we know
like they were wrong completely about
russia and we know that but if
if we figure out who this person really
was uh assuming
this person uh whatever we could learn
about that person
that could change everything and be a
major powerful tool in stopping the
psychopaths
who are destroying our cities who are
romping through our streets who are
infecting our cultural institutions
it feels like assange might hold the key
a powerful tool to ending what the left
is doing
and help restore america back to where
it used to be if we could just get the
truth about
what happened yeah but that's not his
responsibility he's not even american
i know he doesn't know anybody any
favors nobody in america did him any
favors
and this this is why i'm like this is
donald trump's
absolute america first that he would be
like
assange is an american and he needs the
information for america
but also i got to say for himself too it
would exonerate him
right it would it would disprove a lot
of this this nonsense even though
even though it's already been mostly
like proven to be bunk
we'll see what happens with the durham
pro the durham report i'm wondering if
we're even going to see any i i don't
think anything's going to happen with
durham uh
i got to give context for the people who
might not understand so we have uh um
john durham is investigating the obama
like obama administration and
intelligence
uh agency individuals for i guess what
how would you describe it like i guess
the official way is
understanding how russiagate started
although they've already issued one
criminal indictment i think right
that lawyer who altered the email for
like claiming that carter page wasn't
actually a cia's or something
so and this story is so hard to talk
about
you know really scares me about all of
this to truly explain to someone
the context around julian assange what
his information means
why he has to protect it why trump is
going at it there's like 50 billion
stories beneath all of that it's so
difficult yeah it's
very very challenging i've been trying
to explain
my testimony of some friends of mine and
things who don't really follow it they
only really know wikileaks because of
the election
and it's just like an onion like there's
so many layers you have to explain for
each
little bit of my statement like it's it
was
very complicated because a lot of people
only know wikileaks from 2016. they
don't remember
or they were too young or they weren't
paying attention
or it was just the wrong side
politically when when uh
you know the manning leaks came out so
was that collateral murder yeah that was
in the war logs
so like in vietnam they embedded
journalisms and people could see how
horrible it was
uh the the casualty rate on both sides
and friendly fire and then
so they pulled journalism out of out of
the military for the first iraq
invasion basically or war they pulled it
out yeah they don't want they put
journalists in there only as like faux
journalism to make it look good
yeah so seeing this collateral murder
thing you see how
it was just civilians strike like people
just died that was obama
yeah that was obama's dream that was
obama was like no that was before about
that
that was 2010 or something oh it was
before it came out
during which the footage was from bush
it was like a helicopter
gunship mowing down civilians that they
thought were
a camera they thought a camera was a gun
they opened fire on all these civilians
yeah manning described it as like
watching a
child torturing ants with a magnifying
glass because they were shooting them
from the
helicopter and laughing yeah and that's
just powerful
stuff that's military you know they have
to have fun they have to joke about it
yeah
otherwise you'd go crazy so
donald trump talked about pardoning
edward snowden the lead
so uh snowden is this is the nsa leaker
who gave all these
uh files to glenn greenwald and laura
poitras the intercept
and donald trump entertained pardoning
him
don't you think there's a possibility or
do you think there's a possibility he
might after he gets reelected
finally be like okay you know what well
i mean i guess i should
explain what my testimony was about
today
so so this is this is this is kind of
crazy you submitted testimony
in the trial against julian assange no i
wasn't against him i was for the defense
no i mean that the trial is the trial
yeah you submitted evidence supporting
assange
in his ongoing trial extradition trial
right yes so i was supposed to testify
but they the uk court's very different
and the prosecutor for the u.s didn't
want to cross-examine me
which is pretty awesome like he was
scared
but uh they so instead
they didn't have to have me speak they
didn't want me to speak
and so the deal was that the lawyers
would read my statement it's the same
thing they did with jennifer robinson
and a few other
witnesses but they read i had a eight
page statement and
in a transcript of some phone calls and
things that were submitted and they read
that in open court today
and basically
in october 2018 i interviewed julian
assange's mom christine
lovely woman highly recommend following
her on twitter
but she was calling for a pardon for her
son like
no big deal normal article and at the
time i was in a dm
group with a whole bunch of conservative
influencers
and people in the trump campaign and you
know close to the administration
ambassador rick grinnell was in it
arthur schwartz
um a lot of a lot of powerful people and
and
reporters and things and people in the
campaign would post things in there that
they wanted people to share or that they
wanted people to see
so like no-brainer i put it in there
hoping maybe i would find
a sympathetic ear i didn't
so ten minutes later i get this crazy
call from arthur schwartz who
was doing communications for grinnell i
believe he still does
and if you google him he's known as like
donald
trump jr's fixer
and he's he's like yelling at me and
we've always been friendly so i'm like
what's going on
and he starts saying that a pardon is
never going to happen
that they're going to go into the
embassy to take to arrest julian
that they're charging julian based on
the manning release
not on dnc leaks or vault seven
um that he was a horrible person and i
didn't know all the terrible things that
happened because of him
and he was saying that
you know if if you really understood
this
you wouldn't be supporting him anymore
and people will understand
that you've supported him up until now
because you didn't know but now that you
know
if you continue reporting him like
basically you can't be in our in the
cool crowd you're not gonna you're you
know you're gonna be
what what were you supposed to know or
what did you what what was he claiming
you knew now
he was just telling me that he was a bad
person that wikileaks got people killed
which is not
true i mean the pentagon testified that
was not true during the manning trial
and the prosecution said that's not true
during this trial
what could it be the pentagon was was
lying because they don't want to reveal
that they were compromised
possibly i couldn't really speculate on
that but
i argued with him that it was false and
i was like they testified that that's
not true
um and the us government said that's not
true in the extradition
case still but he was insistent that
julian had done all these bad things he
got people hurt that he was reckless
he was comparing him to a drunk driver
saying that he was selfish and
had no regard for other people and
um and that it was basically like
if you keep supporting this guy you're
not going to be in the
cool manga club in dc anymore like
you're you're going to be
you're not going to get scoops we're not
going to share gateway pundit we're not
you know it was
it was an odd conversation
huh did you say fu well
i kept dating her because i wanted i
wanted more information so i was like
tell me more you know tell me more keep
telling me more
um at one point i did start to cry
though because he was screaming at me
that
that you know julian was gonna spend the
rest of his life in prison
and that it wasn't journalism and i was
getting very frustrated and i was
you know i was saying if you go into an
embassy and rip him out
he's a political refugee technically
like you'd be committing an act of war
and he was like not if they let us and
so
i mean i i care about this case very
deeply and so it was it was upsetting to
me
um but as soon as i got the phone i i
think i called chelsea and i was like
hey i think they're coming after you
and then i went and i told julian in
person
and um
the state department got they were
surveilling our
meetings so they heard everything that i
told him
and arthur when i got back arthur told
me that there was state department
investigation
and that he couldn't tell me anything
anymore
because i had told julian he knew that i
told julian
and um yeah sorry there's like a
mosquito but yeah the woods
yup
yeah they they they eventually went and
pulled them out yeah so they went they
went and pulled him out
and i hit up arthur again and i was like
hey you know you knew this was gonna
happen
can you tell me what's going on and um
he was like he deserves the death
penalty everyone involved with wikileaks
deserves a death penalty
completely unhinged and
a few days after that i think it was
like april 15th and he was arrested on
the 11th
there was an article in abc news and it
said that it was like
buried way down this article said that
rick grinnell is the one who had worked
out the deal for julian's arrest
and so suddenly i was like oh that's how
arthur knew all this stuff that he told
me in october
and i hit him up and i was like hey is
this how you knew that
and he was like and then you know kept
ranting about him being
you know deserving the death penalty and
the article also said that
brunel only got a verbal pledge that
there would be no death penalty
so i i pointed that out and he was like
well he deserves
you know what what could he possibly get
the death penalty for um if they try and
claim that
people did get hurt if they had new
charges which julian's not an american
well the un
has warned repeatedly that they believe
there's a chance that the us could try
and
execute him because they could add
terrorism charges espionage charges
patriot act stuff i mean there's a
slew of things that they could throw at
him i'm i i gotta say i'm convinced like
i understand you know trump is going
after him because i think trump
wants to win the fight he wants to he
wants evidence that russia the story was
bunk and he probably wants to help
himself
but i can only imagine if joe biden gets
in they'll kill him
yeah i mean hillary clinton joked about
droning him i don't think she was joking
well i should clarify you laughed about
it yeah yeah but that's because she's
evil
but it's not because it wasn't she
realized julian's in london right
like he's he's a couple blocks away from
this really big shopping malls like his
famous mall
down the street it's like literally
around the corner you can't drone
london if joe biden gets in yeah yeah
the the left absolutely hates wikileaks
right now for some reason
like i guess because of trump because
they think wikileaks was working for the
russians
that is an incredible incredible flip i
remember back in the day
julian assange hero of the left
anti-establishment anti-war exposing the
war crimes
and then all it took was some uh
intelligence asset individuals to go on
msnbc and say oh actually that guy you
like
russia he helped trump and then snap
yeah all of a sudden now they're like
let him burn
and you love this guy man but trump was
the one who
ordered his arrest at least according to
arthur even even trump said he loves
wikileaks yeah but he
ordered his arrest and people should be
putting pressure on him to free him
just saying i think jolene assange
the story is a modern day assassination
story
and what i mean by that is we're not in
the uh
times where information was scarce
there's phones everywhere there's
somebody watching all the time
and if they went to get julian in a
major first world city
then it would be a serious high profile
circumstance where it would make a
martyr
they don't want to make a martyr so what
ends up happening is character
assassination
absurd uh accusat you know indictments
then he gets arrested so he he knows
they're going to try and extradite him
he was right the whole time
julian went to the ecuadorian assembly
embassy because he thought he was going
to get extradited right yep and then
sure enough once they finally got him
out they were trying to extradite him
and the media painted him as crazy for
years they were like he has no reason
to think this he could walk out any time
i mean i spent
years arguing with people about this
people would tweet at me constantly
being he like he could leave any time
he's not under arrest he could leave
whenever he wants and julian would
always be like no i can't though
and he was right and there was like so i
actually met with him several years ago
and there was a creepy black van
chilling out in front
and i'm like i'm pretty sure like as
soon as i walked anywhere near that
building i'm pretty sure as soon as i
got the message the email
like they immediately just ripped apart
all of my you know personal emails all
my files like
all the intelligence agencies from all
these different companies the five i spy
club
did you take your phone to the embassy
did they take your phone back then
they did yeah yeah they took my phone i
stopped really
i didn't bring it for the later visits i
think the first visit i did
but they made you give up all the
numbers and everything and they hold it
up there
they were spying that whole time like
they were using your phone
all these journalists who got spied on
there's only like one
who's even saying anything like hey you
guys spied on me what the hell
i remember that yeah yeah all these
journalists who visited him over the
years though silent
and they got spied on by the u.s
government while speaking to a political
refugee do you insane do you agree with
me about biden though
if biden wins what they'll do to assange
oh yeah i
i hate to even think about i i mean i
don't think that trump is much better
on this but i do think that they will
they would be worse i think glenn
greenwald tweeted about this
someone said why would donald trump want
a pardon edward snowden
and his response was because snowden
like because trump is mad about how the
intelligence agencies and these
individuals smeared him with russia so
yeah he kind of wants revenge right
isn't there a possibility
like that trump is just trying to get
the information from assange but he
wouldn't do
what say like abide administration would
do and
i mean he offered him a pardon you know
not that i agree with that i think
that's a violation
like a serious violation of journalistic
freedoms and in the first right
for us the first amendment i know julian
assange is not an american citizen
but this is kind of scary the idea that
the u.s government could target a
foreign person
like the same thing they did with
kim.com yeah
like kim.com was not an american why did
american resources go into new zealand
and raid this guy's house
they do the same thing to julian assange
it's kind of scary when you realize the
true power of the united states
and their allies and what they'll do if
you're not an american
yeah juice rap news is a great video
about that where they have uh
representatives from each government and
they're like we're america's [ __ ]
oh yeah sorry no that's fine highly
recommend looking for it though
yeah but they don't do the rap new stuff
anymore juice media yeah now it's like a
lot
like i they're they're you know i i've
talked to those guys before in the past
but now it's like
the so frozen familiar juice rap news or
in like 2010 made some of the most
amazing political commentary
music videos like kind of poking fun at
but
in a sense sort of explaining the gist
of some of these things
but uh now it's like a lot of stuff they
produce is just your generic leftist
orange man bad i've only really watched
that one but they
they're doing the honest government ads
now and it's like that's what this was
this was like
but it was a julian assange one oh and
it was it was brilliant
spot-on because i got to tell you man
going back and
going back into 2010 i remember uh all
the hacker stuff
and that's basically how i know you it's
crazy how the hacker community was like
the libertarian left
they and they were they were like it was
very libertarian period
but most of these people in the
community were not right-wing they were
kind of libertarian but leaning left
the government started going after these
people they started giving ridiculous
charges
and julian assange is like the
the remnant of that i guess he's still
facing
this desperate attack from the us
government
against left libertarian style like
hacker individuals
and they've successfully turned the left
against wikileaks
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time